all right let's take a few more calls
from great people in the audience you
can chat with me
um uh
well chat in a in a real sense in audio
visual or i guess just audio via discord
davidpakman.com
discord
let's go
oh i don't know how about daniel from
alhamra
how are you david
i'm doing welcome
i can hear you
all right uh long time member first time
caller thank you um
just wanted to
point out um you know the colin powell
death you know it didn't take
republicans very long
uh to
you know kind of uh
get political with his death um you know
uh republicans tend to you know after a
mass shooting or something like that
you know they they tend not to want to
get too political about the issue
this is not a time to apologize
politicize tragedy they say
right you know and same with alec
baldwin the uh unfortunate situation
there
um i just thought it was kind of funny
that you know the republican uh the
right wingers
uh didn't waste any time politicizing
yeah uh
um but
i have a question for you what would it
take what type of uh or what percentage
of audience
membership would it take to get david
pakman
to have uh like a person go out
uh two rallies
and do kind of like uh you know on the
spot coverage of some of these uh events
that's a beautiful question that's a
beautiful question i would love that um
i think that you know we talk about how
we estimate that somewhere between one
half and one percent of the total
audience
are paid members i think if we were able
to get to two percent we could hire
a full-time person to just go to these
wacky rallies protests and political
events and do
really really good interviews and and
that type of thing i that would be a
really exciting thing actually
yeah i would love it i mean i've been
watching or i've been a member since
your brother was on the show wow
his name yeah um so challenge accepted
audience if you're listening out there
let's get on board and get someone out
on the road to cover some of these
events
absolutely mr david here
thank you very much i appreciate the
call
all right thanks all right very good
yeah that's it i love that idea that's a
tremendous idea actually if you follow
me on social media you know i love
growing my own food in my backyard
garden and our sponsor lettuce grow has
made growing food at home simpler than
ever the lettuce grow farm stand is a
vertical stand that can be inside or
outside where you can grow over 200
varieties of fruits and vegetables the
farm stand waters and fertilizes itself
it does all the work for you you can
grow up to 36 plants at a time
lettuce grow sends you the seedlings and
then your food is ready to eat in four
to six weeks i've had a great experience
with the lettuce grow farm stand i've
been growing delicious tomatoes
strawberries eggplant it only takes up
four square feet fits anywhere i can
move it around very very easy
growing your own food is so rewarding
lettuce grow makes it easy for anyone
and lettuce grow is giving my audience
fifty dollars off the farm stand just go
to
slash
lettucegrow.com
and use the code pacman the link is down
below